[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit anna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in einen tage lang haben sie
jetzt gejubelt quer durchs vereinigte
königreich aber der beifall galt der
queen seit 70 jahren auf dem thron
sobald premierminister boris johnson
seit knapp drei jahren im amt auftauchte
gab es buhrufe der mann hat eine reihe
von skandalen am hals bei den nächsten
wahlen würden die konservativen mit ihm
an der spitze wohl dramatisch einbrechen
und deshalb versuchen jetzt teile seiner
eigenen partei ihn loszuwerden showdown
heute abend noch während dieser sendung
soll sich entscheiden ob johnson sein
amt behalten kann oder nicht aus london
yasin herrlein
im grunde sei alles aus wie ein ganz
normaler arbeitstag in number 10 downing
street zumindest wie eine an dem dort
nicht gefeiert wird boris johnson trifft
die estnische premierministerin zu
gesprächen
dann aber hatte er es eilig im
gepanzerten wagen gut geschützt vor den
lautstark vor seinem amtssitz
protestierenden
trat er die kurze fahrt zum
parlamentsgebäude an dort galt es seine
parteifreunde per persönlicher ansprache
zu überzeugen ihn nicht fallen zu lassen
die überreste des langen feier
wochenendes zum siebzigsten
thronjubiläum der queen waren noch nicht
ganz weg geräumt da stand in westminster
also schon die nächste aufregung ins
haus
bilder wie diese ein zu locker und
zeiten in der downing street feiern der
prämie hatten dazu geführt dass die
dafür nötigen 15 prozent aller
konservativen abgeordneten die
abstimmung erzwangen nach und nach
trudelten am nachmittag die auf die es
heute ankommt vor dem parlament ein die
einen mit daumen rauf die anderen mit
dem daumen runter für johnson
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir heute
einen schlussstrich unter die sache
ziehen können um uns dann anderen dingen
zuzuwenden ich denke es wird ein sehr
schlechtes ergebnis für den premier
geben
sollte er heute noch einmal davonkommen
wird dass jene die mit dem werdegang
boris johnstons vertraut sind kaum
überraschend johnson ist bisher mit
allem irgendwie davon gekommen sein
kabinett stellt sich auf gedeih und
verderb hinter ihn noch
er wird weiter für das land liefern und
auch die nächsten parlamentswahlen
gewinnen
doch diese szene
berufe bei der ankunft johnsons und
seiner frau beim dankgottesdienst für
die königin vergangenen freitag war für
so manchen womöglich das signal dass mit
johnson eben doch keine wahlen mehr zu
gewinnen sind von dem glanz der
feierlichkeiten für eine gefeierte
monarchen ist auf den regierungschef
nichts abgefallen stattdessen hat das
jubiläums wochenende noch einmal den
kontrast verdeutlicht zwischen einer
pflichtbewussten und verlässlichen
königin und dem aktuellen
premierminister
ja so ein misstrauensvotum ist immer ein
schlechtes zeichen für politische
amtsträger auch für die die es über
stehen am ende ist es häufig der anfang
vom ende wir erwarten das ergebnis der
abstimmung in den nächsten minuten etwas
mehr als zehn minuten von jetzt ist es
zumindest geplant in london bringen wir
diana zimmermann dazu unsere
korrespondenten am piano wenn boris
johnson verliert dann muss er seine
ämter abgeben was passiert denn wenn er
gewinnt
dann bleibt er erst mal im abend
allerdings ist es natürlich so dass
momentan die umfragewerte wirklich sehr
schlecht aussehen für die tories und das
macht die abgeordneten sehr nervös
deswegen haben wir jetzt auch dieses
misstrauensvotum wenn man nach den
regeln geht hat er mit diesem tag wenn
er ihn über steht ein weiteres jahr
gewonnen denn die regel besagt der ein
misstrauensvotum überstanden hat darf
kein zweiter dem darf man kein zweites
zumuten innerhalb von einem jahr
allerdings schon gesagt haben alle seine
vorgänger die ein solches votum
überstanden haben ist dann trotzdem
nicht lange überlebt und johnson ist
nicht sehr beliebt bei den konservativen
das war er nie er war nur deswegen
beliebt weil er warnt für sie gewonnen
hat und das steht jetzt tatsächlich sehr
in frage ob indes weiter gewinnt denn
die party gate affäre hat ihn doch an
massiv an vertrauen gekostet unter den
wählern wir hören im hintergrund auch
schon menschen die skandieren ich kann
es nicht genau verstehen ich nehme an es
geht um boris johnson diana gibt es denn
irgendwas was man schon absehen kann
jetzt so wie sonst rufen sie okay kann
man jetzt schon absehen ob die johnson
outet demonstranten am ende dann zu
ihrem recht kommen werden oder wird es
andersrum laufen
das ist mal wieder sehr spannend in
diesem land es erinnert hier überhaupt
alles an die sehr spannenden dragset
abstimmungen die wir den vergangenen
jahren hatten den ganzen tag über hieß
es ist es völlig ausgeschlossen dass
johnson heute weg bestimmt wird die
mehrheiten reichen nicht die
konservativen wissen nicht wenn sie
statt seiner wählen sollen er hat heute
noch einmal eine flammende rede vor den
abgeordneten gehalten und alle seine
vorzüge gepriesen er hat ihnen den
dragset beschafft er hat in die
parlamentswahlen mit großer mehrheit
gewonnen er hat steuersenkungen
versprochen etwas dass die konservativen
die ganze zeit von ihnen wollen was aber
bei der sich anbahnenden rezession ein
ziemlich gewagtes versprechen ist er hat
ämter und posten versprochen das alles
wird ihm wahrscheinlich geholfen haben
allerdings soll er ausgesagt haben auf
die frage wie er es ne party geld
diesmal machen würde jetzt nachdem er
schlauer geworden ist und er soll gesagt
haben er würde alles wieder genauso
machen also wieder partys feiern obwohl
lockdown ist das könnte ihn wirklich
massiv stimmen gekostet haben wenn ich
glaube tatsächlich dass im land diese
stimmung gegen johnson seitdem er die
regeln gebrochen hat und sich jetzt auch
noch so geradezu schamlos verhält in
keinster weise wieder umschwenken wird
und das wollen die konservativen sie
wollen die sicherheit haben dass sie mit
ihnen wieder wahlen gewinnen können dass
sich daran fundamental etwas ändert und
dieses versprechen hat er ihnen heute
offensichtlich in keinster weise gegeben
insofern droht ist doch knapper zu
werden als bisher angenommen wurde es
gibt jetzt schon rechnungen dass es an
die 170 stimmen gegen johnson geben
würde wenn es 180 sind hat er verloren
wir werden sehen es dauert nicht mehr so
lange zumindest ist das die planung und
dann sprechen wir auch wieder in dieser
sendung diana für den moment herzlichen
dank nach london unterhält einer
wirklich ganz schön durch mit den
sprechchören im hintergrund wir gehen
nach deutschland das an pfingsten die
züge voll sind dass es in jedem jahr so
in diesem jahr kommt zu freien tagen und
warmem wetter noch ein sonderangebot des
staates dazu ergebnis stresstest für den
nah und regionalverkehr insbesondere in
urlaubsregionen
die bilanz soll beim neuen euro ticket
ja erst nach drei monaten gezogen werden
aber schon jetzt ist die diskussion voll
entbrannt wenn das ticket zu überfüllten
zügen führt muss ja nicht die tatsache
schuld sein dass es so billig ist
vielleicht fehlt einfach ein adäquates
angebot
an jacob peters berichtet über pfingsten
im zug
sie drängen in die s bahn richtung
strand die reisenden am rostocker
hauptbahnhof
nicht jeder kommt mit
von diesem pfingst getümmel braucht
david erst mal eine pause
seit sieben stunden ist er unterwegs aus
der nähe von dresden an die ostsee und
abends zurück so der plan alles für neun
euro der preis kann man nichts machen
wenn man sparen würde wir dachten wir
machen es mal mit dem probieren sie mal
gucken was passiert
besonders voll die züge die fahrgäste
aus berlin an die ostsee bringen ich hab
ich dann mein sohn auch und als wir
hauptbahnhof eingestiegen sind wollen
wir reingeschoben japan ist es gegen wir
hatten sitzplätze werden glück
nutzer in sozialen medien posten am
wochenende wie es an verkehrsknoten etwa
in hamburg zuging andere zeigen brechend
volle abteile oder dass die
bundespolizei wegen überfüllung räumen
musste zu wenig sonderzüge kritisiert
der fahrgastverband
dazu braucht man die züge dazu braucht
man das personal und für längere züge
braucht man längere bahnsteige und all
das haben wir nicht bevor man ein
solches attraktives angebot macht muss
man eben erst die kapazitäten geschaffen
das sei seit jahren verschlafen worden
sagt der verband und fordert massive
investitionen in öffentliche
verkehrsmittel
auch in richtung tegernsee sind züge oft
überfüllt doch diesmal ist die lage
entspannt pfingst ausflügler haben platz
im regionalexpress trotz run aufs neue
euro ticket super weil er habe es
gekauft auch für die arbeit ich liebe es
uns sammeln wir machen heute aufschlug
ich finde es wunderbar war sohn hätte
auto genau aber mit neuer super es
generell für die umwelt suche ich auch
dass es halt ein effekt hat sie leute
umdenken und in zukunft das dass sich
etabliert ein drohendes unwetter könnte
die massen hier abgeschreckt haben der
ist beim ausflug mit billigtickets immer
so entspannt haben möchte sollte auf die
wochenmitte ausweichen oder beliebte
ausflugsziele wie warnemünde meiden hier
ist der ansturm mit neun euro ticket
besonders groß das ostseebad so voll wie
selten pandemie geplagte gastronomen
freut es
im bereich des tagestourismus glaube ich
merkt man das schon aber im hotelmarkt
glaube ich ist das jetzt nicht so
relevant dass neun euro ticket weil wir
natürlich schon seit langer zeit
ausgebucht sind das eine der wichtigsten
reisezeiträume die meisten spontan
besuchern bleiben also wohl nur ein paar
stunden am strand
und auch david hat es bald geschafft
wer nicht mit der bahn sondern mit dem
auto unterwegs war wird sich vielleicht
gewundert haben wie schnell der
milliardenschwere tank rabatt aus der
steuerkasse an der zapfsäule
zusammenschmilzt man kann förmlich dabei
zusehen
das befeuert natürlich den verdacht dass
die mineralöl- multi es gerade besonders
kräftig in die eigene tasche
wirtschaften und das wiederum treibt
eine diskussion an ob und wie der staat
krisengewinner und kriegsgewinnler
besonders besteuern sollte an diesem
wochenende haben sich eine ganze reihe
von politikern dafür ausgesprochen der
krieg selbst lässt an gnadenlosigkeit
und heftigkeit nicht nach wie laura
panik zeigt
aus einem möbellager im lynskey distrikt
steigt am nachmittag rauch auf die
behörden der selbsternannten
volksrepublik donetzk melden
raketenangriffe auf die stadt laut
prorussischen separatisten seien
zivilisten in der region von
ukrainischen truppen angegriffen worden
überprüfen lassen sich diese angaben wie
so oft nicht
inmitten der erbitterten kämpfe hat der
ukrainische präsident sie lenski die
front in der dom bass region im osten
des landes besucht
ich wünsche uns den sieg passt auf euch
auf das ist sehr wichtig denn das land
ohne menschen wie euch wird nicht mehr
unseres sein
im kampf um die strategisch wichtige
stadt vlotho netz hat sich laut dem
regionalgouverneure die lage für die
ukrainische armee nach jüngsten erfolgen
wieder verändert
wir hatten beinahe schon die halbe stadt
befreit aber die lage hat sich für uns
nun wieder verschlechtert und
[Musik]
auch sie lenski warnt sollten die
russischen truppen im donbass weiter
vorstoßen könnte es schwer werden für
die ukraine indes sieht sich russland
erneut toupiert diesmal wegen einer
verhinderten reise von außenminister
lavrov der konnte aufgrund von
luftraumsperrungen durch europäische
länder seine geplante reise nach serbien
nicht antreten
dies ist eine weitere sehr klare und
lehrreiche demonstration wie weit die
nato und die europäische union bereit
sind zu gehen sie wenden die
niederträchtig ssten methoden an
während die kämpfe im osten der ukraine
weiter gehen könnte es in dieser woche
beim umstrittenen thema getreideexporte
einen kompromiss geben der kreml hat
sich einem medienbericht zufolge mit
kiew und ankara über die freigabe von
getreide lieferungen aus dem bisher
blockierten schwarzmeerhafen odessa
abgestimmt
rund 22 bis 25 millionen tonnen getreide
hängen laut ukraine präsident im land
fest die ukrainische exporte von odessa
wurden laut plan von türkischer und
britischer marine in neutrale gewässer
begleitet später würden russische
kriegsschiffe die getreidefrachter bis
zum bosporus eskortieren so könnten die
hohen preise für lebensmittel auf den
weltmärkten wieder sinken
weitere wichtige nachrichten jetzt mit
diana
bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck ist zu
einer viertägigen nahost reise
aufgebrochen erst das stop heute israel
in jerusalem traf sich herberg unter
anderem zu einem gespräch mit
ministerpräsident
mappus der reise steht eine engere
zusammenarbeit bei energie und
klimaschutz aber auch der nahost
konfliktes thema israel besuch der
vizekanzler außerdem die
palästinensischen gebiete und eine
energiekonferenz in jordanien
drei tage nach dem zugunglück bei
garmisch partenkirchen mit fünf toten
suchen die ermittler weiter nach der
unfallursache laut einem bericht der
zeitung die welt plante die deutsche
bahn auf der betroffenen strecke noch im
juni sanierungsarbeiten
ob ein zusammenhang mit dem unglück
besteht ist nicht klar die bahn teilte
mit sich wegen der laufenden
ermittlungen nicht dazu äußern zu können
unterdessen wurde am unglücksort der
letzte umgestürzte waggon geborgen und
abtransportiert
zudem fand am abend eine ökumenische
gebetsstunde statt um der opfer zu
gedenken
in bonn haben die internationalen
klimaschutz beratungen zur vorbereitung
des weltklimagipfels im herbst begonnen
die chefin des un klimasekretariats
espinosa mahnte dass es dringend
substanzielle fortschritte beim
klimaschutz brauche gerade in
schwierigen und herausfordernden zeiten
gelte ist das ziel nicht aus den augen
zu verlieren
bis zum 16 juni dauern die beratungen
dabei geht es unter anderem um die
einsparung von treibhausgasen um die
unter und um die unterstützung von
entwicklungsländern
ja und wie nötig das alles ist und wie
groß der zeitdruck darüber haben wir
viel und intensiv berichtet und werden
das weiter tun unser süd asien
korrespondent normen odenthal zeigt
jetzt am beispiel eines
landwirtschaftlichen projekts in nepal
das klimawandel nicht einfach bedeutet
immer heißer oder immer trockener
sondern vor allem immer extremer und
unvorhersehbar war er zeigt auch wie sie
versuchen sich dem entgegenzustellen mit
vereinten kräften
wenn die fliegenden ameisen zu flattern
beginnen ist das ein klares anzeichen
sagen die bauern und tatsächlich die
wolken hängen zwar weiter tief zwischen
den bergen aber nach endlos nassen tagen
hört es auf zu regnen endlich für bauer
indra eine gute nachricht
eigentlich war alles viel zu trocken der
heftige regen kam völlig unerwartet wir
brauchten regen aber zu viel ist eben
auch nicht gut das erschwert unsere
arbeit unser leben
die felder abgesoffen die saat
weggespült es ist verrückt denn bauer
indra hat alles oft dürre eingestellt er
hat speicher errichtet und den sonst so
spärlichen regen zu sammeln erbaut
pflanzen an die es gern trocken haben
und jetzt das
dieser starkregen stellt alles auf den
kopf denn normalerweise ist die extreme
trockenheit in dieser region die große
herausforderung die bauern haben sonst
sorgen die sie ihre felder ausreichend
bewässert dieser heftige regen über
einen langen zeitraum trifft sie also
sehr die schnell bei genf oder pharmazie
generika oder schickt der staat die
wissenschaftlerin soll die bauern bei
der bewältigung des klimawandels
unterstützen mit rat und tat wie lässt
sich wasser sparen welche pflanzen sind
robust welcher anbau zyklus bringt
ertrag
das traditionelle wissen der bauern dass
sie von ihren vorfahren kennen verliert
an gültigkeit weil sich mit dem wetter
auch die wachstumsphasen der pflanzen
verschieben sie müssen sich unbedingt
anpassen dazu kommt ja noch dass ich
immer schwerer voraussagen lässt was das
wetter wirklich bringt
der klimawandel trifft nepal spürbar
steigende temperaturen lassen die
gletscher schmelzen die extreme sind
längst alltag von trockenheit und dürre
bis zu überflutungen erdrutsche
der premierminister nutzt jede
gelegenheit zu warnen
extreme klimaereignisse nehmen in nepal
ständig zu und sich fordern immer
größere opfer wirtschaftliche
ökologische und vor allem kostbare
menschen reden etwa 80 prozent der
nepalesischen bevölkerung sind von
klimabedingten naturkatastrophen bedroht
die wissenschaftlerin erika der bauer
intra sie kämpfen denselben kampf gegen
die folgen des klimawandels es sind
kleine schritte gegen eine große gefahr
es ist alles was sie tun können
so und dann jetzt nochmal wie
versprochen zurück zum anfang dieser
sendung 180 stimmen braucht der
britische premier um das
misstrauensvotum seiner eigenen partei
heute abend zu überstehen und um an der
macht zu bleiben die augen liegen jetzt
auf einem gewissen mister brady von der
konservativen partei der das ergebnis
jetzt im moment bekanntgegeben hat diana
wie sie es denn ausgefallen
es haben 148 der 349 tory abgeordneten
gegen johnson gestimmt damit hat er dass
das votum gewonnen er ist weiterhin
premier großbritanniens allerdings ist
diese anzahl von abgeordneten die sich
gegen ihn ausgesprochen hat sehr sehr
hoch deutlich höher als noch bei theresa
may und die hat nach einem solchen dem
misstrauensvotum nur noch ein paar
monate weiter regiert einfach weil das
vertrauen der partei in die führung
zerrüttet war und sie überhaupt keine
abstimmung mehr
insofern muss man ganz klar sagen dass
es ein sehr sehr schwerer schlag für
boris johnson heute abend und viele
gehen davon aus dass es nun wirklich der
anfang vom ende ist eines prozesses der
sich schon sehr lange angedeutet hat der
premier hat zunehmend an zustimmung
verloren hat 2009/10 ein wirklich
hervorragendes wahlergebnis hingelegt
und hat sowohl durch den ersten teil
seiner das management bei der kogit
krise als auch eben durch das brechen
von corinna regeln im party geld
wahnsinnig viel an vertrauen verspielt
war ja abend hat er das ergebnis
bekommen und man muss davon ausgehen das
ist nun wirklich sehr schwierig
verhindert diana da besteht noch mal
ganz kurz nachfragen auch noch einmal
klar zu machen es ist ja seine eigene
partei das kann man nicht oft genug
sagen von der ihm jetzt
148 abgeordnete seiner eigenen leute das
misstrauen ausgesprochen haben kann denn
boris johnson man kann sich die
situation in deutschland kaum vorstellen
einfach jetzt fröhlich weiter machen
weil das alles an ihr abprallt auch
dieses ergebnis oder was werden die
nächsten tage hier zu ergeben
also er ist wirklich bekannt dafür dass
alles mögliche an ihm ab breit ist muss
man so sehen weil die allermeisten
regierungschefs wären nach allem was
ihnen vorgeworfen und auch nachgewiesen
wurde ohnehin längst zurückgetreten die
tatsache ist natürlich dass wenn jetzt
diese 148 abgeordneten im parlament
zukünftig gegen ihn stimmen hat er mit
nichts mehr eine mehrheit also wenn sie
das programm durchziehen ist er damit
erledigt und lahmgelegt und selbst wenn
die regel besagt dass es jetzt ein jahr
lang ein weiteres misstrauensvotum mehr
geben kann kann er dann nicht regieren
es kann allerdings sein dass sie jetzt
versuchen doch mal schwung zu nehmen und
zu versuchen die partei zu einen ich
halte es für eher unwahrscheinlich diana
zimmermann live aus london ganz
herzlichen dank für diese informationen
bei dir heute abend und jetzt geht es
hier nochmal weiter mit sport und mit
hanna der fc schalke 04 hat zdf
informationen zufolge einen neuen
trainer gefunden frank kramer soll das
amt übernehmen der 50 jährige folgt auf
interimscoach mike büskens der den
verein zurück in die bundesliga geführt
hatte zuvor war kramer trainer bei
absteiger arminia bielefeld
jetzt die wetteraussichten
morgen gibt es im westen im süden teils
länger anhaltenden regen und gewitter
sonst ist es freundlicher und meist
trocken die temperatur erreicht 15 grad
an der nordsee und 25 grad in berlin am
mittwoch regnet es im westen bei rund 18
grad häufig im osten scheint bei bis zu
25 grad die sonne länger der donnerstag
wird wechselhaft und kühler der freitag
freundlich bei 20 bis 26 grad
so viel von uns danke für ihr interesse
erst morgen wieder für sie da ihnen
jetzt einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]